what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here today so i was gone
this morning and most of the early part
of the afternoon but this trailer came
out and then i put out on the community
post three different trailers that
dropped which one should we cover and by
very overwhelming popular vote it was
this one red notice starring dwayne the
rock johnson ryan reynolds and
gal gadot
we both do great israelis awful all
right let's check this out we only got a
few minutes to do this because we have
to do an interview with andy lee from
marshall club and chongqi plays a death
dealer in that let's do it
[Music]
special agent john hartley fbi
dwayne johnson every movie
i have this charming delivery to
everyone
you become the world's most wanted crips
nude cow whispering
wow
looking for something specific or just
browsing you're under arrest oh my god
oh
[Applause]
we both know that this whole thing is
going to end
with you and anchors
promises
they remade the bbs scene
can't stop that snyder cut
whoa
well that looks fun they put in his name
front and center that looks like a lot
of fun yeah here's the instant thought
that i had the instant thought it looks
like every one of their franchises
slapped into one movie they like bought
the popular action comedy franchises
from reynolds dwayne johnson and then
there are parts of here from gal gadot
that feels straight up not wonder woman
but diana prince yeah you know artifacts
and yeah
exactly so many of those qualities and
then like the comedic banter that you're
gonna get like that is the most uh once
you tell me ryan reynolds and dwayne
johnson are in a movie together the
first thing i'm gonna think is oh comedy
banter and then having a team up but
they're probably not really gonna get
along but they're really to get along
you know and that's kind of the the
flare that we got here i didn't really
get a full sense for what the tone is
because they have this like remix of the
notorious song over it that's probably
edited out of this video so we don't get
copyright claimed by the music companies
but they have that flair over it and it
seemed like it was trying to have like
the cool slick vibe but it also
the scenes that they were like when the
music wasn't going seem to go all for
comedy so absolutely there's some like
tonal inconsistencies in the marketing
i'm not saying it's the the movie or the
overall marketing uh but yeah there was
something about the tone that wasn't
specifically clear to me or maybe it's
meant to be a variety of all those
things
like like their respective franchises
that they're all in i mean there is a
certain amount of hollywood mathematics
you can kind of feel from this because
it does feel like you took three
individual starring vehicles and then
smashed them all together but you know i
mean the scope and scale looks fun the
camera work looks very sort of fluid and
expressive so this looks like it has a
lot of energy and parts of it almost
made me think of like and i don't know
if this is a weird take but especially
with dwayne johnson i was like i can see
him almost inching slightly towards
maybe a more guy richie place in the
future playing those kinds of characters
those kinds of like gruff but not
necessarily like the biggest action
stunt guys even though this does look
like it will go into huge action stunts
yes so i'm not saying he's there yet but
you know like that kind of was a neat
little note for me to catch because i
was like oh maybe this will be kind of
where the rock heads in the future but
for right now i mean this just looks
like three personalities we like a lot
doing a whole lot of action stuff i mean
honestly i don't need a trailer for it
if you if you tell me you got these
three actors in a movie i'm immediately
gonna assume what the genre is and i'm
gonna assume the kind of film we're
gonna get and this is pretty much it
this is almost exactly what i would
imagine them to do and i don't consider
that a bad thing i wouldn't expect them
to go for the heavy the one that looks
like they're doing something a little
bit more refreshing would have to be gal
gadot because gal gadot is like the
antagonist character here i thought it
was going to be like a
team up or something and maybe there is
some ultimate team-up thing to happen
but it still is this cat and mouse game
that they have going on so she seems to
have a little bit of that devilish grin
throughout and you know it's like with
her it's like oh come on guys this looks
like hobbs and shaw and the gal gadot
fast and furious and diana prince yeah
and
it looks like skyscraper looks like red
lipstick looks like hitman's bodyguard
yeah it looks like all these it looks
like underground six yeah it's got some
jungle recruits player and it's got like
all their franchises slapped into one
and so i'm actually so curious about
what the
collaborative process was behind the
scenes because ryan reynolds is known to
have a bit of creative control when he
is in a starring vehicle dwayne johnson
same exact thing known to have some
creative control and they seem to get
along really well behind the scenes ryan
reynolds even has like a little role in
hobbs and shaw and they like talk on
social media publicly a lot so i imagine
the talk behind the scenes a lot so i do
wonder what the collaborative process
was ultimately like like who was real
alpha on set for all this i imagine it'd
be dwayne johnson yeah they cap it off
with written and directed by ross and
marshall thurber and i'm like who worked
for doing johnson on skype skyscraper
but i'm like how much of that was you
writing and directing this versus you
just taking ryan reynolds with the rocks
and that incorporating your own when
there was space for it i mean wait the
action is directed feels similar to the
skyscrapers
there was nothing in the action that
felt entirely unique and that's
something that i would hope this movie
does deliver on like even like the
coolest money shots i feel like i've
seen in other stuff when the more
ridiculous it gets the more crazy it
gets that's the stuff i most appeal to
currently because like one i don't know
if they're like some like gladiator
coliseum yeah and there's like an animal
like what the hell is going on here dude
or something like so weird being
matadors right now
yeah i want a trailer that doesn't try
to be as like super cool and edgy as
this trailer was trying to do i just
want something that lets you just hang
out with the cast because i feel like
that's what we're all going to show up
for more than anything else is just we
want to hang out with this cast we want
to hang out and see some cool action
every 10 minutes yeah
but guys what did you think about the
trailer thank you guys for voting for
this this is fun and i'm definitely
going to watch it we're most likely
going to do a reaction to it as well
comes out november i'm excited for it i
really am really excited for it
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button thank you so much for voting for
this one and hey we'll catch you guys
soon
gotta shout out maria hammond because
she sent this to us in the mail look at
that
my goodness i am still so in awe of what
she had developed for us there's a whole
story with her having to like find the
right photos take it to them she didn't
like it she said tear it down do it
but she brought this to life and it
feels so lived in it really is like it
it doesn't look like just fan art it it
feels like we're
we're really like oh wait we have we
were guest stars in rick and morty
it feels like that remember that so
maria thank you so much i love the hell
out of this photo so much this is this
is absolutely incredible thank you so
much my dear
[Music]
you